Bill Clinton a accueilli solennellement
Jacques shirac à la Maison Blanche tout
à l'heure pour la première visite
officielle d'un président français aux
États-Unis depuis maintenant 12 ans
s'exprimant devant le Congrès Jacques
shirac a appelé à une adaptation
indispensable à ses yeux de l'OTAN et il
a proposé un partenariat global entre
l'Europe et les États-Unis sur place
pour France de filles
parir même Grégory Peck était parmi les
invités il faut remonter à 1984 pour
qu'un tel cérémonial se déroule à la
Maison Blanche en l'honneur d'un
président français visite d'État et pour
Jacques Chirac l'occasion de montrer que
le lien entre la France et les
États-Unis est ferme même si l'exigence
des relations entre les deux pays
provoque parfois des Remus l'arrêt des
essais nucléaires aidant le paysage est
dégagé et le président Chirac
porte-parole de la Maison France et de
l'Europe en profite pour lancer trois
messages aux Amériques la France milite
pour une alliance Atlantique rénovée
avec une défense européenne jouant
pleinement son rôle au sein de l'OTAN la
France veut élargir son partenariat
économique avec les États-Unis enfin la
France rappelle que les pays les plus
riches doivent faire face à leur
responsabilités vis-à-vis des plus
pauvres trois messages réitérés devant
le Congrès des États-Unis avec une
insistance particulière sur l'aide au
développement ce qui sonne comme un
reproche vis-à-vis des
Américains le maintien de notre aide aux
pays qui ont besoin de nous est une
exigence morale
qui s'impose à tous il est aussi le seul
moyen de désamorcer une véritable bombe
à
retardement qui nous menace tous et
menacera nos
enfants n'abandonnons pas à leur sort
les pays les plus pauvres de notre
planète notamment les pays d'Afrique si
les paroles de jacesirac sont bien
reçues par le président Clinton
conscient notamment du rôle majeur de
l'Europe elles sont moins bien
accueillies par le Congrès qui penche
plutôt vers un isolationnisme américain
c'est pourquoi Monsieur Chirac va
répéter plusieurs fois son message ici
aux États-Unis pour être certain d'être
sinon compris du moins entendu et de